les gusta el helado
levanten la mano a quien le gusta el
helado
a todos les gusta el helado
y a mí también me encantaba pero durante
mucho tiempo al menos diez años no comí
más de un día para el otro es que decía
que no me gustaba o peor el helado dejó
de gustarme de verdad
pero bueno yo no estoy acá para contarle
de lados ni tampoco sobre mí chifles que
son varios sino para contarles cómo
funciona la otra bocha la que tenemos
acá arriba de los hombros como llegamos
a hacer lo que hacemos cómo llegamos a
ser quienes somos
el riesgo que corremos de quedar
atrapados en nuestra propia historia así
y si tengo un poco de viento a favor que
voy a necesitar quizás le pueda contar
algunas pistas de cómo salir
pero empecemos desde el principio
desde chiquitos todos escribimos un
cuento nuestro cuento y lo hacemos para
saber quiénes somos qué hacemos qué nos
gusta que no mira yo tengo dos hijos
anita que tienen tres y medio y benja
que tiene dos
con mi mujer muchas veces jugamos a
imaginar adivinar cómo van a hacer
cuando ellos sean más grandes
anita cuando sea adolescente no nos va a
dar bola en nada en nada va a ser súper
desafiante en cambio venga venga quizás
sea más tranqui vago seguramente nos va
a hacer renegar con las tareas y eso
pero va a ser más fácil de llevar y
podemos imaginar esto no porque tengamos
una bola de cristal que de hecho no la
tenemos sino porque ya estamos leyendo
su cuento y estas son las páginas que
seguirían estoy seguro que el que tenga
hijos nietos sobrinos o hermanos más
chicos alguna vez habrá jugado a esto no
ver que sigue en el cuento pero bueno
esto no es cosa de chicos ustedes todos
tienen su propio cuento el que va atando
las distintas experiencias en el tiempo
su forma de sentir su forma de pensar su
forma de actuar
es así todos tenemos un cuento ahora
quién escribe este cuento quién lo arma
ustedes se sentaron alguna vez con una
broma escribirlo no lo hace su mente y
lo hace solita lo hace sin pedirles
permiso sin consultarles demasiado todos
los días pasa tiempo ordenando las
imágenes las experiencias fijando ideas
fijando formas la mente es como un
editor saben qué hace un editor de
libros se fija que no haya errores se
fija que la historia tenga una secuencia
cronológica ordenada pero sobre todo que
sea consistente que sea coherente que no
tenga contradicciones
el editor nunca es una figura visible no
aparece como el autor del libro pero es
muy importante su trabajo
su mente es el editor ahora hay
historias que nos marcan a nosotros y en
esas historias del editor pone el foco
lo que se dice lo que se explica de esas
situaciones lo transforma en verdades
después de esas verdades las guardan la
memoria y esas verdades son luego las
que nos van a definir las que nos van a
señalar el camino
a veces son situaciones grosas como
todos hemos vivido otras veces
simplemente una palabra nos puede marcar
incluso a veces son boludeces yo les voy
a contar una una noche un amigo mío de
toda la vida rodri me dijo en un boliche
luke y papá poseen cara total el no ya
lo tenés una de cada diez te va a decir
que si yo les aseguro que todavía lo
puedo escuchar a eso fue exactamente así
yo era muy tímido manera terrible [ __ ]
así me sentía si actuaba así estaba
escrito en mi cuento pero por alguna
razón esas palabras de rodri me animaron
en un instante una verdad de mi cuento
una verdad de mi editor se rompió y a
partir de ahí cambió mi cuento empecé a
encarar como loco esa misma noche
confieso que igual no ganaba nada pero
bueno tengo que admitir que esa es otra
historia así con momentos situaciones
nos vamos armando un día nos decimos las
cosas de una manera el editor transforma
eso en una verdad y a partir de ahí su
trabajo va a ser sólo uno sostener la
coherencia
a partir de ese momento nosotros vamos a
pasar todo un tiempo reforzando lo que
decimos y para eso el editor se vale de
toda esta máquina atiende a las cosas
que le interesa borra filtra saca las
cosas que no encajan y hace fuerte las
cosas que si se ajustan al cuento que se
está contando
me creen si les digo que el editora está
inventa cosas para que la historia
cierre mejor porque lo hace por eso el
editor más que leer la realidad la
inventa ajustando las cosas que pasan al
cuento que escribe
ahora voy a volver un poquito mi
historia del helado total ya estoy
entregado
los domingos nos juntábamos en casa a
comer asado siempre mis viejos somos
cinco hermanos algún novio alguna novia
a veces primos a veces tíos éramos
muchos después de la ceremonia de la
entrada del asadito y levantar la mesa
venía el postre helado
uno de esos domingos cuando me
ofrecieron dije que no no me gusta el
helado
lo cierto es que yo sí con mi lado y me
encantaba pero este domingo dije que no
ahí el editor escribe una verdad y
después a defenderla pasaron más de diez
años hasta que algún día me habrán hecho
mejor sinapsis las neuronas me pregunte
no me gusta el helado
me fui caminando la tardecita hasta el
freezer aquel potter mira a los costados
no quería que nadie me viera si yo no
comía al lado
le clavé la cucharada sopera del dulce
de leche todavía medio congelado y me lo
metí
me encantaba el helado claro que me
gustaba el helado a todos le gusta el
helado
entre ese pote como el peor domingo de
lluvia y depresión hasta bajarlo y ahí
me di cuenta en ese momento me di cuenta
la verdad que no me gusta el helado se
derritió sola
ese domingo en casa estaba todo muy bien
todos charlaban disfrutaban la pasaban
lindos compartían y yo era ese
era adolescente estaba peleado con la
vida estaba peleado con el mundo lo del
helado no tenía importancia dije que no
porque yo no estaba en esa sintonía de
disfrute dije que no porque no estaba en
esa comunión de felicidad eso era lo
importante en mi cuento estar enfrentado
no del helado o pura casualidad pero al
editor se le quedó pegado y después a
sostenerlo en el tiempo y acá lo
importante
todos construimos nuestra identidad en
base a verdad es que un día compramos y
después ya no cuestionamos
a pesar de que cambien los contextos y
me refiero a las cosas grosas no [ __ ]
como lo del helado
es así y por momentos puede ser un poco
triste
les cuento una cosa más porque todo esto
pasa sin que nosotros nos demos cuenta
la mente editora hace todo este trabajo
sin que nosotros lo notemos y en parte
está bien que sea cierto tiene una
función biológica y evolutiva muy
importante imagínense ustedes el tiempo
que les llevaría cada día al despertarse
contarse quiénes son qué hacen y al
final del día agarrar todas las
experiencias las imágenes y ordenarlas
como si fueran un álbum de figuritas
imposible no podrían hacer nada más que
eso por eso la evolución le pasó esta
función al editor para que haga todo
este trabajo de hormigas sin jodernos
sin consultarnos para que nosotros
podamos disponer de nuestro tiempo y de
nuestra atención para otras cosas por
ejemplo estar ahí sentados disfrutando
de ted mientras su mente escribe el
silencio
yo sé que suena bastante cómodo esto de
tener a alguien que haga las cosas por
nosotros pero créanme que hay un peligro
enorme en este juego todo lo que decimos
que somos no es más que un manojo de
supuestas verdades que un dia redactamos
lo bueno y lo malo después es el editor
el que les da fuerza a esas ideas
valores sensaciones actitudes que tantas
veces nos definen nos condicionan y por
esa [ __ ] manía de ser coherente el
editor termina más reforzando lo que
dice de nosotros mismos que buscando la
manera de cambiar y de crecer y nosotros
me enterados
seguimos en piloto automático
todo eso que decís que no podés cambiar
que te tenés que resignar no son
verdades
quiero que empieces a pensar que son las
mentiras de tu editor
quiero que dudes hasta de tu memoria
porque ahí también mete la mano muchas
de tus trabas quizás hayan sido ciertas
cuando las armas test pero después
caprichos del editor quiero que sepas
que el editor está entrenado para no
soltar esas verdades es un dóberman no
debe hacerlo no sabe hacerlo eso lo
tienes que hacer vos
mi historia del helado puede ser una
pavada puede ser divertida pero yo no
podría explicarles cuántas limitaciones
cuánto sufrimiento trae quedar atrapado
en el propio cuento yo lo veo todos los
días de mi vida es mi trabajo esto de
intentar desenmascarar al editor igual
no dejo de sorprenderme ahora
cuál es tu historia del helado yo no
quiero que hoy se vaya nadie de acá sin
antes haber pensado dónde está el helado
en su cuento porque esta es la única
vida que tenemos no da para dejársela en
consignación a otro no da para ser meros
intérpretes de lo que la mente nos dice
en fin
está en cada uno de ustedes
abrir los ojos
mirar adentro cuestionar hasta la última
verdad de su cuento y reescribir lo para
que no sea tu editor quien escribe a tu
destino sino vos salud
[Aplausos]